all right so
um
speed up your style
is
what got me excited about this uh
presentation
so we all know that browsers are
evolving uh constantly what was you know
good practices in 2013 is not good
practices anymore or you know has
changed a little bit
so because browsers are evolving you
also have to kind of
keep uh up to speed and keep changing
what those criterias that made for good
performance work in the client and
browser side
uh so you have to read a lot you have to
be aware a lot you have to follow those
industry leaders that we all know of and
you have to keep playing to see what
suits and fits your needs
um
so these are a few of my favorite things
for performance
that's my favorite thing for life
but i so i'm just gonna focus instead of
like going all over the place i'm gonna
focus on svgs uh inline images or data
uris
uh progressive jpegs
uh optimizing through css properties or
you know when not to use css properties
like uh
we can get to that later and about css
selectors you know what can cause bloat
what won't um
so the first thing svgs
they're great uh if you're using like
you know logos in your site who doesn't
you want to use svgs they're scalable
you know they're smaller than png's
um
you can js of them make them smaller you
can optimize them make them even smaller
um the best thing is that because an svg
a standard vector graphic is basically
an xml like document it has a dom like
element so you can use javascript to
kind of manipulate that which is what
you know you end up doing in d3js
uh you can write styles for it if you
give classes
to your uh you know svg
and you know you can also run media
queries on svg so if you want to like
have an svg show differently on a mobile
device versus a desktop browser you can
do that
um
so i wrote a very simple
test
for
svgs i just used uh
a logo
and
wrote
let's see
right
so this is a very simple
um html file where i use
that here
guy
and use an svg
like so
and have a display so oh the other good
thing is that on retina displays the svg
just shows up better
um
and it's smaller so i run quick test um
on one of my browsers
which i have
on this guy
so if you'll notice that there's
basically just two calls on my page one
is the html itself the other is
uh the html here
uh svg is like takes about three
milliseconds the png takes about four
milliseconds so this seems like a small
amount on uh on just the one page with
the one logo over time it becomes you
know a big uh a big gain for a site that
wants to be really performant so the
reason i ended up using this is because
of this site which was all parallax it's
the mobile version of hbo.com
not the mobile the ipad version of
hp.com and all these guys this guy that
guy that guy that guy because it's going
to be seen on retina devices you want it
to look really clear and sharp so those
are all svgs and it also means that
because parallax is such a heavy
uh load on your site you're basically
saving some few kilobytes and some few
uh
milliseconds on loading this guy
um
all right let's go back to the
presentation
so that's just a comparison that we just
saw
uh you get bonus points of course so
apart from just having smaller
files the small sizes you can optimize
the svg a little more a typical svg when
you generate it using illustrator would
look like
would look like this a lot of crap right
we don't need
comments we don't need all of that you
kind of clean that up either by hand or
there's tools that can automate that
process for you there in my slide i'll
share that with you later but you clean
up the white space you clean up the
comments you get a smaller file
and
win all right
and then of course ie8 does not support
it every other browser does you can
polyfill it using modernizr and just
replace the svg with the with the png on
i8
um so like i said they're great for
icons logos mats they scale really well
if you have a large
image on your uh browser so like google
maps or whatever you can use like an svg
to do that really well but if you want
to be redrawing it because the svg is
being rendered on the browser site and
that's drawing it you don't want to kind
of
use it in video games you're better off
using something like canvas
um
all right
inline css images so that's the other
way you can
reduce your page load
so one of the key things that
bottlenecks are pages you know the
requests that go out for resources and
assets in css
if you use data uri which is basically
converting your binary image into a
base64 code and then embedding it in the
css
you're going to make one less request
looks something like this
so this is a normal
background image being used
if you were to use uh
an inline image in the css it would just
basically be this again you have tools
online if you you know look up base64
encoded images you can just get that you
know upload your png get this
and place this here um
and again there's a
there's a good
performance benefit
so i read another test and in this case
you had this is the regular png
and in this case you had two resources
you know three milliseconds each
in that case because the html is gzipped
and it's smaller it kind of compares
with the original html that had
the the png
and
there's no cost for
for the png itself because it's embedded
all right
and the other good really good thing is
that because the image is going to be in
your css css is going to be cached you
can set long expires on your css so
you're going to basically keep that css
for two days three days in a browser and
it's just gonna use whatever is in that
tss so that makes it even faster
um this actually works in ie which is
great
and it's great for desktop browsers last
year someone from mobify came up with a
blog where they tested ransom tests on
using data uris in mobile devices
and it seems like
mobile devices is not there yet when
they have to actually decode that image
the base64 image and paint it again they
take a hit in you know processor print
processing and
battery too so for now maybe we're not
ready for mobile devices
uh progressive jpegs have been talked a
lot
um
it's almost like going back to the old
days of the internet but it's kind of
great because
as a user you see something and you're
not left with a blank image
progressive jpegs basically means that
instead of saving your jpeg as a normal
jpeg you save it as a progressive jpeg
in photoshop or whatever tool you use
it's a little bigger than your baseline
jpeg which is your normal jpeg ruling
the internet right now
um but but like uh
story and stefanov says if your sizes
the size of your file is above 10k
then it's not that big of a difference
he also says because the ratio with
which the progressive jpeg is bigger
than the baseline jpeg is only a little
bit you're kind of always better off
giving the user the illusion of having
some something there instead of like the
content jumping when the image is done
loading
um again desktop browsers the support's
kind of there especially with chrome
mobile we're not there yet wait a bit
optimizing css selectors for people who
like portlandia
no use optimizing css selectors anymore
so we used to all you know kind of keep
our
selectors uh
less bulky
and um last year you know paul irish you
can't have a presentation without a
polaris tweet announced that you don't
really have to worry about selected
performance anymore because you're doing
more harm than good you know maybe
sacrificing readability for performance
and because browsers are so fast now
when they calculate uh selectors it's
it's we're good to go um
and to that it sent um
chrome devtools used to have a css
profiler where you could see how much
you know was being called for each style
how much selector was being called for
each uh
style they don't have that anymore they
removed it as of last year
a better way to maybe uh
you know have your css be reduced
is to just remove all unused css there's
enough tools there
on github people have repos there's
ways you can kind of run your code and
see what part of the css is being used
and what isn't
um
the last thing i want to talk about is
css properties
love them right who doesn't you can just
use radial gradients linear gradients um
instead of images
but you have to know when you're using
css3 properties like box shadows like uh
you know border radiuses those pretty
borders on your buttons
they do take a hit not on the load
itself but on the painting when you're
painting the page with those special
properties
it might um you know slow down your page
while painting a bit especially some of
them are used together like if you use
border radius and a shadow on a button
just going to bring down uh the way the
page paints
but it's still better than using images
and with that
stock is over
thank you
just have a few links there if you guys
want to
go through them these are the tools i
was talking about for you know encoding
for
you know removing your css for uh
you know knowing your browser this is
really important because this is a great
like 30 minute video that talks about
everything from how the browser first
gets the request to rendering painting
layout
thank you
do you have any questions oh right
questions
really guys questions you just had pizza
point of the blue screen
right
they probably should right i mean feel
free to
uh not agree with me but if if you kind
of take the svg code
and put it on your html if right
it's okay
it's hard to get emails
it's hard to get email clients to even
get anything beyond html4 so support for
svg seems unlikely but svg has been
around since forever it's not like a new
year and yeah
what is you what is usable inside of the
old outlooks
tables use tables for emails
pizza
another question but the comment it
would be interesting to see for the
image
to use svg instead of
oh that's actually a good point i forgot
to mention that but in the hbo website
it's actually an svg that's been used as
a data uri
so it's the best
yeah it's the two the best of the you
know both the worlds together good point
um
that's that's also true it can just be
an xml yeah
so that's true but because you embed it
and because you gzip your css
there's like a three percent difference
between your
css with the png versus the css with the
the base64 encoding
it's a little bigger like in my case the
difference was a few bytes because i had
a very tiny
you're going html
uh
128 percent to 64 bit sets you're going
to get approximately 30 percent larger
but the perfect gzip is going to save
you 30 on an english text file
so it turns out you got the same size
that's true you save on that and
the big the big performance hit for b64
is just that the browser is going to
have to decode it instead of just
showing the image so you might want to
hold off and using them on mobile
devices
that's true
so and then you have just one logo which
you know you can have extra text in your
logo use media queries
right and your sprite could for all you
care be a data ui
thank tool